this week we went back to Ann Arbor the
land of controversy hard workers
professional protesters and my show what
are you doing what for this last week
there's been a lot of controversy at
University of Michigan for banning a
showing of American sniper due to some
students claiming they feel unsafe that
it's racist now the whole shebang but we
decided to go straight to the source and
get the info for you take it from the
top baby
all right so every Friday night the
University of Michigan hosts you mix
which is a time for students to be able
to come out it's an alternative to going
out and drinking on campus right yeah
it's a time they have events where they
host movies that they'll do open buffets
anything for students and so this
particular Friday they were going to do
American sniper as the movie
unfortunately there were a group of
students who started a petition or a
letter and they said that they were
going to be offended by the movie
because nice girl yeah IVs Chris Kyle's
a racist and because the movie
perpetuates negative in misleading Siri
they actually say he was a racist yes
they did in their letter and they said
he was a mass murderer and so the
university I think within 24 hours of
receiving the letter cancelled the movie
and they said that because people were
going to be offended and disturbed by it
that they were going to not show it and
instead they were gonna show Paddington
Bear yes they replaced American sniper
with Paddington Bear because Paddington
Bear hates America
what did that many students really feel
unsafe for they're really that many
protesters I had a hunch what's your
opinion on the school's involvement with
American sniper I wasn't a big fan of
how they first canceled the movie and
replace it with a children's movie and
then the movie back on wait that sounds
entirely reasonable
this is scooch scooch I'll come sit here
with you I felt that it was a patriotism
to Christopher Kyle and what he's done
for our country I think that he should
be very well Valerie for what he's done
that sounds far too logical we need
something to sensationalize and what if
I were to call you a racist
yeah I believe it they stood up for what
they believed in
well I think that if you look at the
controversy and you compare the films
that they have I walked off and then
they were just kind of trying to comply
with every single different person's
right wants and wishes instead of making
one decision sticking with it hey mr.
flasher McConnell let me smell this oh
for sure there's liquor and this isn't
there no it's just water sir I'm very
much sober and that the both films have
been about you okay let me ask you this
if I'm gonna be so bold I'm a white guy
clearly you are we're just bringing the
racial divide here it sounds to me like
you're saying Allahu Akbar if you were
to call me a racist I raise this agreed
hi disagrees present no I have a
liberation out what do you consider
yourself a freedom fighter consider
myself the barrel risk this is at it
this is paddington terrorists are you
not aware look he hates America terrible
did not come through the head oh it's
just a such a terrible pun thank you
would you know about racism well um I
have been called the n-word many times
in my life oh yeah but have you ever
have you ever blown up a terrorist have
I blown up a terrorist racist why does
why does everything have to be a thing I
think a lot of movies these days make
all the veterans out three races even
though they're not racist against
Muslims they just want to get rid of the
terrorists
you guys haven't you guys been doing
little bit of boozing have you no
justice later okay well then I don't
technically know how legal it is for me
to interview your on camera because that
you can technically go back and say
since you regretted it that I raped you
I know about this you didn't rape me
but there's a freedom of speech to try
and get the school to shut down a film
and then get the film removed isn't that
kind of like removal of freedom of
speech from other people uh true yes I
could agree with that oh you're from the
left side that I'm from YouTube ah
YouTube that you hate because you're a
racist
get this get him you just said he was
just headed out but not no I'm not
is that bare Admiral Ackbar no a little
bit it's okay no I'm not that race I
don't I I don't have self-loathing so
paddington terrorists bear how do you
feel about displacing one of the
greatest American heroes of our time and
Chris Kyle well it's not my fault Steve
how do you figure that
well I blame the Jew it's a free speech
issue where one side is not saying hey
we want to express our opinion oh we
disagree right one side is saying nobody
else should be allowed to hear another
opinion ban the movie so the file that
the flyer that they're handed out was a
little confusing because that sort of
made it seem like you thought all
Muslims to savages which they are right
and so they're taking it onto social
media and some of the ways that they're
going about it I disagree with it and I
think that they're taking a little bit
too far something some piece of the
interpretation of the movie it's not an
offensive move in the first place and it
was dumb done in the first place okay
let's say it were offensive like Blazing
Saddles
shouldn't you still be able to play it
if they want to anyway yeah its freedom
of speech we have a right to be offended
yeah exactly you're the right to be
offended I have the right to you know
offend you
in Vegas and I could exactly so I know
some of you will be disappointed you're
waiting for the gotcha but that's not
the case here the real takeaway is anti
sensationalism okay not one student we
spoke with not one thought that the film
should be banned or even went as far as
to say that it was offensive a very
small contingency of people were talking
single-digit numbers
decided a protest right and because they
have a friendly media it became a
national story just like the 60s was not
an era of hippies or flower power most
people couldn't stand them right now we
live in an era where the people who
scream the loudest no matter how
irrelevant they are get the megaphone of
a complicit media most people just want
to go to their classes most people just
want to do their job because it's
America any of these suck like this
video subscribe by clicking my face or
watch this video playing in a box next
to me that also centers around free
speech and media sensationalism also you
get to see me dress up like a gay guy
and that's homophobic but it's funny